[Music]
good morning today's a beautiful day we
have um some special guests here Zoe and
Maya being all cute why are you guys so
cute you know who else is super super
cute super super duper duper cute
my boys hi what are you guys doing
I was just recording some video footage
of him and he started farting a lot so
that I was like do I need to like take
you off of this because we don't want to
stain this this is our photo shoot um
blanket so I was like do I need to take
you over there to
release some farts I know we just
finished taking pictures of this little
guy for his three months and two weeks
update every single week we've been
taking photos yeah we've been using the
nice camera to uh yeah that one two
photos and videos and to document his
growth right and with the lights you're
like you put the lights out here
cutie oh my God you're so cute you're
kicking my hand oh what's going on
oh my mom's calling me oh my mama
Abuelita is calling hello Luca
hi baby well they're up here hanging out
I'm gonna go downstairs and make some
breakfast
okay breakfast time man you know what
I've been having this blemish hair on my
face
for like weeks it's actually gotten a
lot better thank goodness but this will
not go away like I don't know why but
anyway for breakfast I'm gonna do a
shake Casey likes his almond toast with
his coffee this is really cool coffee
that we get that's frozen what am I
gonna eat every day I'm like you know
what I gotta I got I got so many options
I've been trying to consume more oatmeal
because oatmeal is really good for
breast milk production is what I hear
you know what else is really good for my
breastfeeding body ritual shout outs to
Ritual for sponsoring today's video so
I've been adding this ritual essential
protein to my shakes every single
morning it tastes so delicious and I
just absolutely love how I'm able to now
meet my body's increased nutrient
demands with rituals essential protein
because it contains all nine essential
amino acids with inadequate amounts
which means it's a complete protein it's
also vegan soy free and gluten free and
it's formulated without GMOs I also love
the fact that ritual raises the bar with
the quality because they make sure to
test every single lot of protein to make
sure that you're getting exactly what's
on the label they also work with a
third-party lab to help ensure their
products are compliant with regulations
and guidelines for heavy metals microbes
and major allergens so that makes me
feel at ease that I'm not putting
anything harmful into my body or passing
anything to Luca I really love how this
protein powder is so delicious it tastes
like vanilla but you really taste that
creaminess and it's not like other
protein powders where you can actually
taste the fact that it's a protein
powder rituals essential protein hits it
out of the park for me I really love it
and like I said I love adding it to my
milkshakes I every single morning I add
some fruit in there some oats some chia
seeds and definitely I got it add my
protein powder
I love good so I recommend rituals
essential protein during and after
pregnancy highly highly recommend so you
can check out ritual.com tiffcase20 for
20 off your first month or you can just
use our code toothcase20 at checkout to
get the discount you can also check out
the link in the description to check out
ritual and they also have protein for
adults 18 and older or 50 and older that
is not specific to a postpartum or
pregnancy so if you're trying to add
high quality protein to your diet check
them out highly recommend them
let me go check on my baby
what happened FaceTiming with uh Mama
yeah and then and then he started crying
we were both laying down oh yeah it
sounded like he got hurt so I'm like oh
my god what happened oh hi Mama
I'm scared here and yeah yeah hi
so what happened I think he was just
like I'm over this I don't want to lay
down no more I don't know I mean you got
tired of laying down or maybe he wanted
to show Mama yeah his other side it's
like all you ever showed them is me
smiling I'm more I'm a complex human
being let me show you my other emotions
I know what's going on bubba okay I'm
gonna see you in two and a half days I
know they're gonna be coming so soon
yeah
he's slapping now smiling yeah he's like
yeah I'm gonna meet you yay
food's ready oh my sweetie he's like
rubbing his face oh my baby how's your
nap
you took a nap while Mommy was making
breakfast
so I made a shake with oatmeal chia
seeds shredded coconut oh cutie smiling
at it too you didn't get marks on his
face too oh my shirt
uh rituals essential protein shake
vanilla shake with mango strawberries
spinach
that's it I was gonna put honey but the
protein powder already has like really
like the perfect amount of sweetness
along with all the fruits so I decided
not to taste it you've never tasted it
so let me know what you think
does it taste like protein powder
it tastes good what's the texture wait
don't finish it that's for me
[Music]
you're just getting heavier I know this
arm is buff
right how do I look am I getting buffed
too oh yeah I think I think I might I'm
shrinking I need a
get healthy again I know honestly I'm
the opposite I'm blowing up so I need to
get healthy again too but honestly I
feel like we we need to like just get
back into it we need to get back into
our healthy routine yes take them out
more in the nature we've been wanting to
go hiking with him we should go hiking
today let's go hiking today you want to
go hiking baby after after breakfast
yeah it's a Saturday what do you want we
slept in it's okay we're fine it's a
Saturday
hey cutie I made myself
uh bagel with cream cheese very New
Yorker it's a Saturday like a bagel
cream cheese I'm busting my chops here
all right once again I'm hungry it's
okay you got it you got it
[Music]
you've got it dude try rolling rolling
over ah you've got it bubbly
yeah good job big boy big boy caring now
this is the first time I have his leg
sticking out usually he gets carried
with his legs in like a newborn you
ready for hiking let me get your hat it
is time to go hiking it is a very hot
day in Southern California we're gonna
make sure baby Luca here is protected
from the Sun and from the heat as much
as possible this is our first time doing
anything like outdoorsy and like mine is
the beach yeah minus the beach yeah well
that's true but that day wasn't it was
windy but it was very relaxing because
it wasn't very hot yeah this is Toasty
sure
oh you're wearing your Mavericks gear
I love his voice that was the first time
I haven't foreign yeah how is it it's
like a roller coaster you're on a ride
you're on a safari ride see what kind of
wildlife we're gonna see today it
doesn't feel as supported somehow as it
would be if it was facing towards you
see
[Applause]
[Music]
he doesn't look comfortable at all
[Music]
here we go this feels better
[Music]
I kind of looking around
you know he's sleepy see all these trees
this is the world we live in Luca not
inside the house like that's all you
know anyway it's bright out here
hey top down the swing
just something Isaac was looking forward
to the last time we came we were uh we
had a field day over here swinging here
oh well
[Music]
uh-oh our first obstacle
of the hike
you can do it
[Music]
just walk in the water though if uh if
you got a bale
[Music]
look I have to get my shoe wet
to not fall I could feel it soaking up
my sock just a tiny bit does it feel
good though because I feel like it
that's actually a good problem to have
on a super hot day
no it's cool feet
you fall asleep
he's like oh I have a soundtrack of
nature here true if he goes to sleep to
waves it's either waves or white noise
or classical music or something
now he has a nature soundtrack so he
feels at home then yep I'm definitely
breaking the sweat this is definitely
physical activity yep yep yep I think
it's the first time I've
gone out and done something active and
like since uh Luke has been born so it's
about four months of inactivity and I'm
definitely feeling it as I walk I could
feel my back jiggle oh yeah that's fun
the excess mask that I have I have games
to provide support for this one I can
feel it jiggling
I'm not useless it's like a massage
while you walk this is literally the
first and only time in my entire life
that I've really felt like oh man like I
gotta work out like I gotta
I'm gonna lose some weight like I've put
on more than I'm comfortable with and
I've never felt that in like 32 years of
life like really it's the first time I
felt that so it's a different experience
a different sensation but I've I'm still
trying to be very mindful of
appreciating my body being thankful for
what my body has been able to do to
provide life
so I'm still very much loving my body
but I just want to give my body the
healthiest
you know wait because I really feel like
out of breath I feel way way less energy
lethargic yeah lethargic
so that's how you know I'm like Oh my
body is asking for attention I need to
give my body some attention now
next step is to uh run it jog it maybe
baby stuff baby steps okay
[Applause]
oh my gosh it's nature it's not flying
away I'd be oh oh gosh I think that's
amazing Isaac the butterfly Whisperer
what the heck can I get you on camera
what oh snap is it hurt
that's weird though yeah is it tickle
is it going to go
baby go nice
bye good luck on your journey
[Music]
my parents are finally in town to meet
Luca
you guys ready to meet Luca yeah getting
ready
it is
[Music]
thank you